a web of secrecy could make it nearly
impossible to identify a plane's real
owner and whether the plane is even
still in operation
the Boston Globe spotlight fellow spent
a year investigating a system that the
paper says can be exploited by drug
dealers or corrupt international
politicians the team reports had even
found people with links to terrorism who
appeared to hold active FAA licenses to
fly or repair the planes Kris Van Cleave
spoke to the reporters who broke this
story he's at Reagan National Airport
that's right outside Washington DC of
course Chris good morning good morning
the stories are out in the Boston Globe
today and what they found really raises
some questions about how the FAA handles
information regarding airplanes and who
flies them one in six private aircraft
in the United States are registered
through means though legal make it very
hard even for law enforcement to
determine who owns an airplane it's a
system the Boston Globe spotlight team
found is appealing to bad actors like
drug runners flying this American
registered plane shot down by the
Venezuelan Air Force people can use
layers of secrecy to register their
aircraft and those layers of secrecy are
really attractive to drug dealers
criminals corrupt politicians and people
with potential ties to terrorism Jaime
Dowdle and Kelly Carr are the spotlight
fellows who reported the story it helps
them hide conceal their activities and
they have when they register their
airplane with the US flag it's like
getting the US stamp of approval what
they found was an antiquated system less
secure than getting your driver's
license you have to have a bill of sale
and the bill of sale simply says Kelly
sold the plane to Jamie and and then you
have to fill out the form and that's
about it
because you go to the DMV it's a birth
certificate a passport a power bill the
cost of registering an airplane is just
five dollars a price the FAA says was
mandated by Congress back in 1964 the
FAA doesn't see itself as an act of
policemen of the registry so when
information comes in they make sure
information is there but they don't vet
the information so they're really
operating on the honor system of people
who are registering aircrafts and also
on pilots licenses
to say this is who I am I am a US
citizen you know I live here
but if somebody has bad intentions and
wants to lie or has ill intent for the
use of that license or you know
certification of a plane they can lie
and the FAA says that they're not going
to vet they're not checking the FAA
acknowledges it does not vet its records
because it does not have the resources
to determine the accuracy of information
submitted for registration the globe
found two of the planes used in the 9/11
attacks were still listed as active
until 2005 and the FAA didn't cancel the
registration of a TWA cargo plane that
crashed in Chicago in 1959 until 57
years later if those aren't being caught
imagine what else is slipping through
the cracks like two United Airlines
pilots who were convicted of trying to
fly an airliner drunk as of September
1st
they still had valid pilots licenses
although the FAA says they wouldn't be
able to fly because they lack a current
medical certificate or five people the
globe identified with potential ties to
terror who were listed as having active
FAA licenses as recently as August
airplane mechanic Tyrod nathan webster
pugh currently serving 35 years for
trying to aid Isis showed up in the FAA
registry as a valid license holder the
FAA says despite what the database
showed his license was revoked in 2015
you can find the story online at globe
comm slash secrets in the sky
the FAA told us in a statement it has a
team that investigates fraudulent
aircraft registrations and says it is
constantly working to strengthen the
integrity of registry information the
agency is developing a plan to
significantly upgrade and modernize the
aircraft registration process Chris
thanks